[Music]
two summers ago I was sitting in my
living room blew it to the TV screen the
most important race of the Olympic Games
Rio 2016 was about to begin the men's
100-meter butterfly swim final now let
me set something straight I am NOT a
sports fan I barely even make it to
Arriaga gym and I live or just cross the
street but this race was different
the usual big names were swimming
Michael Phelps from the US shotlock Lowe
from South Africa they were the
favorites tout it to win it was going to
be a very tight race but these weren't
the guys I was watching the race for I
was rooting for a young boy called
Joseph schooling from a little country
called Singapore now I want you to watch
lane 4 with me just three in the pool
but we are history
that's Singapore to my little chameleon
place and then a little bit recon time
did you guys see that
my jump but also his win our first
Olympic gold as a country 50 years of
Independence
now first gold and I still remember the
pride I felt when they played our anthem
and raised our flag the tears that came
to my eyes and I was just sitting there
watching my TV screen there was probably
one of the proudest moments in our
country's young history but the odds
were stacked against us so few people
thought we will make it to the final
much less make it to the top but our boy
Joseph he had a dream David against
Goliath the little country that beat the
odds that day
Joseph fulfilled his own dream but he
also fulfilled the dreams of an entire
nation hoop in its hopes on him I'm not
a competitive athlete I'm a public
servant but in so many ways it's really
not that different I think about how
competitive my country is going to be in
the global race for talent resources
investments development I think about
what nation my country wants to be and
how we're going to get there how do you
build a nation a nation is built on
stories like Joseph's stories of dreams
your dreams mine our families our
communities but also the blood and the
sweat and the tears that we poured in to
get us to where we are even Martin
Luther King had a dream a nation is
built on all those dreams and the
discipline and the sacrifice they got us
here just 50 years ago Singapore was the
third world country nearly independent
from the British no natural resources
it was during this time my grandparents
raised a family when the country had
almost nothing there were no industries
no jobs it was about survival then not
about dreams my mom growing up remembers
one packet of noodles being shared
amongst five children one pair of shoes
passed down from child to child the by
the time we got to my youngest aunt
it was tattered and torn my grandfather
can only find employment as a clerk of
the police force and even then his
meager salary of $200 a month wasn't
enough to raise a family of six and so
he had to double up as a watchman at
night life was tough but that was life
then everyone thought that this new
country would fail you couldn't even
find us on the map read that small but
that didn't deter us our leaders were
determined that this little country we
would not just survive we would thrive
now the u.s. had 300 years of
development to get to where it was at
that time we didn't have that luxury of
time and so we embarked of
industrialization and globalization at
the same time because they knew then
that in order for this country to make
it they had to create employment create
economy but most of all create an
environment where people could hope
could aspire and could dream and so we
went out to look for companies you will
not look for investments and we realized
that the only way anyone was going to
invest in us was if you offered them
something that other people couldn't
stability transparency and a
pro-business environment it meant
everybody had to fall in line including
the unions
and so they came in droves some of our
earliest investors American companies
hewlett-packard Texas Instruments
they're still there today and they came
because of the political stability
because of the determination of the
people and because of the commitment of
the government so they built factories
hired thousands of people people
including my family members their
neighbors and their friends by their
very presence these companies required
local services and so that gave my
parents the chance to be small business
owners start their own company be their
own boss because that was their dream
and as Singapore came from third world
to first my family also moved up
socially and economically there by the
time I got to me I could be anything I
wanted to be that could be a doctor an
entrepreneur Miss Universe that was a
privilege I grew up with I speak three
languages I've lived on three continents
I love Shakespeare soliloquies as much
as I love Elvis as blue suede shoes and
I'm just as comfortable having burritos
for lunch at our bucco as I am having
Chinese food I am Who I am because of my
family and also because of my country a
country which today has a per capita GDP
comparable to that of the US and we're
just five and a half million people we
also have one of the most spectacular
skylines
not biased I didn't end up being a
doctor or an entrepreneur and I guess
not Miss Universe either I found my
calling in the public service where I
get to make people's dreams come true
whether they aspire to be that
entrepreneur that doctor start their own
business be the next Mark Zuckerberg
spend the rest of their lives coding in
front of a computer or networking with
the world's business leaders my job is
to make those dreams come true I get to
build industries I get to bring the
world's best companies to Singapore why
so that I can create the economy the
employment and the environment so that
these people's dreams can come true
so we've won the gold where do we go
from here
what got us here 50 years ago it's not
going to get us to next 50 years
economic empowerment brought us social
mobility but it also brought a whole
host of challenges like social
inequality and we have to address those
challenges as we build for the next 50
years the next hundred years as you
continue to build the country for people
to dream we started off as a nation that
beat the odds we did it with discipline
hard work sacrifice when Joseph's
schooling won that gold medal and he
brought it home he embodied not just our
dreams but all the values that make us a
nation 50 years ago we would never have
imagined the day we are one and on the
big gold medal and we did
with our dreams and with our values and
if Singapore can beat the odds this
little country then perhaps other cities
and other countries can too after all a
nation is built on dreams thank you
[Applause]
[Music]